hello friends I'm keep replacing Lucy
for this festive ish edition of reality
check as we take a look at 2015's best
gaming science this year might forever
be remembered as the year the movies got
really really paranoid about rogue AI
but we're here today to celebrate the
coolest science stuff that hit the
headlines in 2015 maybe we can make it
the year video game studios remember
that space is cool instead one of the
best things about gaming is that it
creeps closer and closer to minority
report every year before the 2002 movie
went into production Steven Spielberg
gathered together a group of 15 experts
to brainstorm about what technology
might look like in the year 2050 for and
since then scientists have been racing
to make it a reality there's even a
dedicated spot on the Wikipedia page for
things we've made reality smugly
declaring humanity's awesome science
power to the world what makes minority
reports interfaces so damn cool is that
that augmented reality they don't
replace the whole world with graphics
like virtual reality does they just
layer things on top of what already
exists Microsoft's e3 hololens
demonstration might have been slightly
over exaggerated but it did show how far
a our technology has come when the
Minecraft world popped up on a
strategically placed on stage table the
crowd's reaction gave away how much it
felt like watching something from an
ambitious 80s sci-fi movie there was
also a demo on the show floor where
players were shown a brief for a halo
match reminiscent of the holograms and
Star Wars but with significantly less
experimental hairstyles and it's not
just games either we've seen a are quite
a medicine designed the home anter horn
obviously this is the future friends
but one thing Minority Report didn't
predict was smell-o-vision probably
because that idea has been forgive the
pun boo food by people for decades why
would we want to smell what we're
watching do we have to smell sweat when
watching sports does it get fishy when
we're watching Deadliest Catch well good
news for your nose smell-a-vision is
kinda a thing now with the feel real VR
mask just like those 4d experiences you
get at Universal Studios this mass can
produce eat cold wind mist and smells to
immerse you fully in whatever game
you're playing at the time just hope
it's not Mario because he's a plumber
after all it's a nastier down here but
don't worry you don't have to Don a
mouse to experience cool science because
this year we also saw procedural
generation being brought back into the
public eye this method of programming
allows developers to create huge world's
varied textures and a much higher degree
of randomness than they would be able to
produce in a typical development cycle
it relies on algorithms generated by the
computer under certain guidelines
created by the developer now this method
of making games is nothing new as far
back as the 70s games like elite we're
using the technique to compress large
amounts of information and locations
into limited file sizes at the time
elite contained eight galaxies each
containing 256 planets elite dangerous
the game sequel which came out in 2014
expanded the use of procedural
generation to establish around 400
billion star systems the current big boy
in the procedural generation playground
is no man scheduled for release next
year which boasts over 18 quintillion
planets many with unique flora and fauna
it's not just huge games about space
that use procedural generation either
indeed steampunk heist game the swindle
uses it to generate its building based
levels making sure that it's a different
challenge every time XCOM 2 has
procedurally generated levels which
means as Lucy put it you can play XCOM 2
forever and indie developer Tom Francis
has been detailing the design process
behind his upcoming game heat signature
as he refines the algorithms that go
into generating new spaceships oh I said
there wasn't gonna be any more space
games didn't I
light the point is that procedural
generation is no longer just a necessity
it's also become a design choice our
final science and gaming moment takes us
back to minority report again cloud
computing which enables us to share and
save resources online was apparently
refined to become the model it is now
after companies were inspired by the
high tech sci-fi film according to
Hewlett Packard but when we're not using
the cloud to download homework and store
are thousands of selfies other people
are using it to do incredible things in
the world of gaming this year d 3
Microsoft showed off crackdown 3 using
the Xbox one's cloud computing to
maintain an impressive cityscape and of
course to allow for its destruction
typically games would rely on just one
consoles computational power to render
explosions which limits both the size
and the scale of your pyrotechnics the
idea with crackdown is that players
might want to destroy an entire city in
a gigantic domino effect ball of fire
and the only way of doing that is to hop
onto multiple servers to keep the
architectural destruction running
smoothly its technical wizardry that
lets us blow stuff up what more could
you want smell-o-vision explosions and
the endless void of space you'd be
forgiven for thinking that we were in
the actual future despite all those
think pieces that got all sad about not
having hoverboards like Back to the
Future promised which is maybe for the
best be sure to let us know your
thoughts what do you think the best
science in gaming was this year and what
are you looking forward to next year let
us know in the comments or come find me
on Twitter I'm at how not to draw thanks
for watching 2015's last reality check
and we'll see you in twenty sixteen for
more
you